today's results of the evaluation show
we did the right thing with this
voluntary approach the results showed
that the platform's have taken their
obligations seriously and more companies
are joining the code in 2018 for new
companies came on board here we see
Google+ Instagram snapchat and
dailymotion and today I also want to
welcome the French gaming platform video
come on board the average rate of
removal of illegal content has slightly
increased from last year and it is now
stable at 71% just let me remind you
that at the beginning when we started
this exercise in 2016 we were at 28% in
addition almost 90% of all notifications
made by social media users and trusted
trackers are now reviewed within 24
hours this is a good results and it
relates to one of the key commitments of
the platforms to tackle the majority of
cases within one day
the only real gap that remains in is
transparency and the feedback to users
who send notifications on average about
a third of the notifications do not
receive a feedback detailing the
decision taken only Facebook has a very
high standard sending feedback system
systematically to all users so we would
like to see the progress on this in the
coming months likewise the companies
should be more transparent towards the
general public about what is happening
on their platforms we would like to see
them make more data available about the
notices and removals the companies
themselves changed their approach many
of them now call for regulators to take
decisions on artificial intelligence or
on online content they realize that a
hands-off approach does not help to
build or regain the trust of their users
this is the crucial moment for the tech
sector either they will prove that they
can play fair and embrace the rules that
exist in the offline world or they will
face regulatory actions or men on many
fronts it is time to balance the power
and the responsibility of the platforms
and social media giants